so today we're going to cancel this man
ryan dorsey
and all his kind all his ilk he's a
baltimore city council mayor uh
member i should say i don't mean that
kind that's not the kind i'm referring
to
um though sure we can cancel the
baltimore city council i guess why not
they really haven't been doing much good
recently
and by recently i mean for the past i
don't know five decades or so
but that's not the point today the point
is this tweet from dorsey
um and there's a picture there of a
fedex truck and a bike lane in the city
and it says
quote hey fedex i told your driver here
to get out of the bike lane he was
obstructing which i happened to be
biking in
his response was get a car
now needless to say this fedex driver is
awesome
ryan dorsey on the other hand is the
lamest dork this side of justin trudeau
not only is he riding a bike and
bitching at a delivery guy
but after the delivery guy verbally
backhands him he posts his own
humiliation on social media thinking
he'll get sympathy
from the public rather than the
relentless mockery and scorn he deserves
quick tip here even for people who
aren't lame dorks
when the internet has to choose between
sympathy or scorn
it will always choose scored always
so keep that in mind or learn it the
hard way as
ryan dorsey has but this behavior is
what i would expect from dorsey given
that he is a cyclist
cyclists and i mean those who ride bikes
on the street
and you know streets those things where
cars go
those kinds of cyclists are a cursed
breed
they are among the worst people on earth
the absolute
dregs of humanity no one no offense
intended
every time i'm driving down a busy
street and traffic is backed up for
miles
because everyone has to navigate around
some weirdo on a bike
i am perplexed anew how is this even
legal
i think to myself why are we allowing
people to ride their bikes on roads
where cars are supposed to go now i get
that you want to exercise that's fine
but why are you exercising in the damned
street
during rush hour i like to exercise too
i'm not gonna set up a bench press on
the freeway i'm not gonna take an ab
roller down to the nearest intersection
hey give me a minute i got three more
sets all right hold on
why why won't i do that because i'm not
a lunatic and i care about other people
sort of at least i'm not gonna go out of
my way to make their commute longer and
more stressful than it already is
i'm not gonna do that cyclists do that
now what gets me about the bike riders
is their sense of entitlement it's not
just that they have the audacity
to play with their toy in the street
it's that they they get angry at you
for being there they act like you are
inconveniencing them
they act like you just jumped on the
same elliptical that they were using at
the gym
but the street is not your elliptical
it's a street
if you want an elliptical go use an
elliptical
and if you want to play with your bike
go to a park or a bike trail in the
woods
or maybe daddy can take you down to the
tennis courts near the playground
so you can ride your big wheel around
maybe that or better yet ditch the bike
and be an adult
find a hobby that isn't as likely to
make you a victim of vehicular
manslaughter
just a thought now i know i'll be told
that some people use bikes as
transportation
not as toys or exercise equipment fine
but the street
is for a certain type of transportation
vehicle transportation if you can use
your bike as transportation on the
street
then why can't i use a pogo stick why
can't i pogo down to work
maybe the city will be maybe the city
can build me a pogo lane
just for me you know why can't i take
this office chair right here it's got
wheels
i just roll it down the highway why
can't i go out to 10th avenue and do
cartwheels for five blocks i'm just it's
just transportation
hey this is how i get to work all right
i cartwheel to work
we all have our methods why not because
again that would be insane
and the road isn't made for it the road
in fact is made so that five thousand
pounds hunk
five thousand pound hunks of metal can
fly down them at high speeds that's what
it's there for
it's not made so that middle-aged
vegetarians and spandex shorts can burn
off some calories on the way to work
commuting is not a time for burning
calories anyway that's the other
annoying thing
the rest of us are jamming donuts into
our fat faces while we sit in traffic
and stew in our own body fat and misery
and you're riding by all brisk and
healthy
and happy it's irritating
especially around thanksgiving and it's
grotesque
and it's dangerous and it's an
inconvenience to me
so cyclists are canceled take an uber
next time
no more bikes they're not allowed that's
it
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content